so when I went to college that she was
like national Geographics for me I was
just observing people in the bush you
know look at the way they high-five it's
way different
yeah there's they don't do that they
just touch it they walk away you know
I'm like that's how these groups like it
was like a wild thing to me man
yeah and so like even like greetings
jokes like even white people food you
know I mean like I know why people like
hamburgers and [ __ ] but like I was so
ignorant like I remember I talked to my
friend Kail
I was like yo Kail what are why people
eat what do you mean I was like you know
aside from like hamburgers hot dogs he
goes no casseroles yeah is that
casseroles where you take stuff in the
fridge and then you just put whatever
and it's white it's white paia it's like
the white yeah what is it what does it
call it an Asian culture fried rice it's
fried rice it's white people fried rice
I was like oh [ __ ] that's your fried
rice and I started collecting [ __ ] I
said what we do is we take our chicken
feet and we chop the [ __ ] and we throw
that you know we throw like random [ __ ]
in there that's why like when I watched
what's that show that Joe Rogan used to
be on as the host Fear Factor uh-huh
that [ __ ] used to crack me up do it
doesn't people much luck
how do any people feel about fear factor
in the rating question it's just lunch
yeah they would be up there they would
just be like oh like Joe Rogan is like
you have to eat [ __ ] bull balls and
my parents are like that's pretty good
you know and there's nobody scared yeah
the fans are like oh wonder what recipe
they're going to use like you would
never see an Asian person off you're a
factor dude because it was just a normal
Sunday you know I mean they're like you
have to cross this river swim and then
survive I mean like that's how I came
here anyway
yeah no the Delta is flooding but yeah
that's it
wow man it's so crazy like if somebody
has to bring up a clip of just like a
legit Asian person being on fear factor
because that's nothing it's almost like
I'm faking it huh they're either faking
or they think they're just recreating
their life how they got here like Joe
Romo you got to build this boat and go
across and save that person that was me
let you me you know they would just go
over swim you know like it was so funny
oh is this it no I reminds me of Tyrone
Biggums on Chappelle yeah he handled
everything he was a homeless crack
addict and he handled everything on fear
factor and this is Rogen on the show no
oh yeah Rogan played himself on the show
but he he eats a
yeah a buffalo penis no problem he's
like oh I get an extra free meal that's
exactly what that [ __ ] was because they
would talk about stuff on fear factor as
if it was something nobody has ever
eaten but I grew up eating that [ __ ]
right like this oh yeah dude when I was
in Shanghai even I mean I know that's
China and it's not Korea but it's like
the things they had like in a gas
station as snacks yeah the things they
sold on a train is snacks it was like
Talan like animal Talon hawk or some
kind of hawk or maybe a you know a
strong strong Sparrow you know pigeon
could have been a [ __ ] pigeon with
like you know like a you know kind of
cleft palates in its feet or something
but like huge talons with like in a
barbecue sauce and a gaunt like it was
like what and you'd see some [ __ ] kid
just sucking on the toenails I mean like
oh [ __ ] this is an important thing to
talk about too so some people here that
leo what is he saying is like you can't
say [ __ ] that Bo cuz he went there yeah
there you know I didn't mean so I like
for me it's like you say it I'm like
that she's so true you know cuz like
when I wasn't to me that's so scary
right yeah but then also like I grew up
eating crawfish so if you see somebody
and you're not familiar with it and even
the Vietnamese people said I'm putting
you know just general but Vietnamese
people love crawfish I got some big
thing in their culture right but it's
like seeing somebody eat something
different than you do
it's sometimes it's [ __ ] baffling man
yeah even for me like there's something
I can't eat that a lot of Asian people
eat it's a tripe which is like that
inner lining of a cow's stomach [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ] but Asian people eat that
[ __ ] like it's a delicacy now like I
swear like our people are so dope
because in the sense of we whatever
white people thought was trash Asian
people are like that's delicious you
know I mean it's almost like what the
[ __ ] is going on right now man and we
eat why people eat cracklins which is
basically like we'll fry up pork fat
right yeah so it's kind of like it's not
the same as tripe me you guys are going
way deeper than the fat like cutting the
stomach out after which i think is
bizarre but asian people don't like to
waste things